[Applause]
[Music]
i'm writing a new song
it's gonna hit you hard i thought you
were my man it'll get under your skin
right down to the ball
it's gonna be a whole new vibe that
brings people together
i'm just unlinking your chains
well you only got three chords ah
we'll make them sound like a million
bucks chain change
[Applause]
[Music]
in recognition of all you've done the
people of the world
hereby crown you queen
also
[Applause]
make sure the world only sees the aretha
franklin you want them to
yeah you're gonna remember her name
aretha she's too young to go out there
[Music]
it's easier for a woman to be the help
made of a king
than it is for a man to be the helpmate
of a queen
don't let that queen thing go to your
head i don't let that clean thing go
wherever i wanted to
[Applause]
time to change it and i want to keep
changing with it
you got to disturb the piece when you
can't get no peace
[Music]
this is what you were meant to do
[Applause]
you just got to launch your power
[Applause]
there will never be another one like me
you